Courtney Cox is of course Jennifer  Aniston's dear friend and when Brad Pitt  and Angelina Jolie split last week  Jen's name was all over the story even  trending on Twitter right after the  breakup news Tuesday et caught up with  Kourtney at Revlon's annual  philanthropic luncheon the actress told  us she just doesn't agree with people  bringing up Jen's name as part of the  narrative right yeah I feel like we're  exacerbating it buddy was talking about  Aniston has stayed quiet since the news  though her husband Justin Theroux is  doing press for his new movie the girl  on the train  et chatted with him on Monday about what  makes their marriage work we appreciate  each other sense of humor we respect one  another we get along you know I mean it  sounds simple but it's true